I want to talk to about three different
things you can do today to increase the
value of your business number one build
systems that outlive you if a company
it's built on a lot of different systems
one can come in and look at the system
and say great this is a system boom boom
boom here's what I need to do that adds
value to your business because it
outlives you number two is protocols on
learning have a blueprint that has steps
on how everything is used in the company
here's how you use this software here's
how use a CRM here's how we handle
complaints here's how we handle this
here's how you enter this the more of a
handbook there is with our protocols on
what to do that increases the value of
business because a learning increases
fast and last but not least being the
business of replacing yourself replace
the talent when you were handling money
with a CFO replace when you were doing
all the operations with a CEO replace
the part you were doing with you know
going out there meeting everybody with
someone that's in biz dev replace your
software technology replace yourself for
sales because the more leaders you
replace yourself with and the less the
company needs you the more increases the
value of your business
you